thank you
foreign
oh
am I live
sorry I was just uh
getting some words into my brain yeah
I enjoy literature
hi everyone
it is true
we have hit a milestone in this channel
and I'm here to uh
celebrate with you all as one does you
know
and I have a big announcement
first off before we really start the
festivities
hi everyone yes hello
I want to make a statement
hello
in this statement
may surprise some people right
it might shock some people
yes hello
and you may say
you may say Jake
why are you dragging this out
why are you adding suspense right
what is the point of that
and I say to you
you don't understand live streaming
and I do
because I'm a goddamn streamer now
that's not that's not the announcement
though no no no
Jimmy is here
the fantasy Network
thank you sir wonderful wonderful person
you should go subscribe to as a booktube
channel
now the announcement
Nadia will be joining us shortly I
assure you don't worry don't worry you
know you don't have to put up with me
the whole time all right
the announcement
is that I have not
I have not even been trying
this whole time
every video
400 videos
I haven't been trying
well guess what
I'm going to start trying now
that's right guys I'm gonna start trying
and the videos are gonna be so good you
guys have no idea what you're in for you
have no idea what you're in for
yeah surprised so am I because I just
realized it
and now after that announcement that I'm
going to start trying
I'd like to present you oh thanks
I'm finally good enough
the legend herself oh my God
you want me to read
be in this big couch because you know
I'm your assistant I just wanna you're
too big for me now I just want to make
sure I'm useful
I just don't want you to threaten
divorce now so I'm kind of a big deal
it's a big deal yeah but so are you
because I'm with you in fact one might
say you're the biggest deal
with your being your groupie
uh not quite
um so thank you everyone for being here
and now we're really going to start the
stream we have a few things on the
schedule but first we're getting some
crazy like things in here people are
donating money which you guys do not
have to do that's overly generous
Elliot you convinced me to finish Das
Capital year so you're the best wow
that's wonderful I'm really actually
kind of surprised about but that's great
I mean that's a long book
um will you make more Stormlight videos
I got in the series to understand your
skits
um you know I think that if you do
continue reading the series you will
understand all of this gets better I
mean I think that there there are
there's a lot of subtext in all of my
videos that I really try to to to bring
from Stormlight so there's a lot of uh
key details that you might miss in my
art if you you know
don't read The Stormlight Archive
um congratulate thank you Nemo too
wow you guys are are really on here
doing some crazy stuff they're not
they're not they're not AI they're
really on there I think they're really
on here whoa all this time I thought it
was AI
is this for real that's Peter just said
sent
99.90 that's insane you're outdoing me
come on
that's really nice and thank you thank
you everyone
um so I'm going to be sincere here and
maybe like T minus 10 minutes but you
know I have to put on the ACT I have to
do the song and dance here for a little
while because
um it's overwhelming you guys are
wonderful I'm really grateful for for
everyone who's here and who has been on
this
Epic Journey
just an Epic Journey
I don't know that's what people say
right
um I'm actually like sweating my balls
off right now in this like jacket it is
summer
um hello Jake this is coming out of my
week's pay what's your favorite Calvin
okay don't do that that's okay thank you
that's very kind but you you know save
your money
um but that's that's very nice my
favorite Calvin Calvin and Hobbes story
arc oh man I mean I I really love like
um
anytime they're doing like dinosaur
stuff like any dinosaur involved
shenanigans on Calvin and Hobson of
course no Snowman snow people
um
wow this is you guys are really nice
this is this is really really nice
um to see all of this I mean I don't
know like
when is The Meta textual skit about
asteroid City dropping I haven't seen
asteroid City yet yeah oh real quick
everyone
before we you know
get further into the stream I do need to
say that subscribe to woman carrying man
that's I'm I'm not gonna plug this all
the time I'm gonna be disappointed
no you're what are you talking about you
gotta hype it up you got to be like yeah
under death threat for the rest of his
life wow he did not sign a bring up guys
oh my gosh Carson Reckless hey thanks
thanks for being here I I love
I listen to All of suck UPS though I'm
I'm a big fan that got me through the
final season of succession
um
yeah for sure
yeah you guys are amazing I'm really
behind yeah I'm sorry guys I'm really
behind
um will there be more Dark Tower Wheel
of Time review videos well I I do have a
big um book compilation video coming up
soon
um so we'll we'll see we'll see but yeah
Dark Tower for sure
um Wheel of Time we'll see I don't know
I I I'll probably do something about the
new season uh when it comes out but
um
oh uh what is your opinion on drama
around yeah yeah good try good try but
you know I'm not I'm not this isn't my
first day on the internet guys
um congrats on 300K guys your stuff
cracks me up every time I just found you
on the channel as well lover and hearing
your take some other directors congrats
again thank you very much yeah yeah go
check that out we just did a review of
dial of Destiny on the second Channel
and um
then I also did like a I do director
rankings on there sometimes we just did
like one ranking
um 299k Bots and me yeah that's probably
that's probably how it works yeah I mean
I don't know I mean at this point it's
kind of like um I just assume
um you know most of you are just like
robots that live in my brain that aren't
real
um
thanks for the 10. uh do you think that
Dune should get movies for all the books
or just a few of the sequel ones also
congrats thank you so much
um
dude I think it'd be funny if they got
uh sequels for all of the books I'd love
to see God emperor of doing you know
um
turn into a movie
um well I don't know if any of them is
the one to capture that that kind of
surreal intensity you know I have
opinions on doing that I won't get into
but um
these are my living shakes
my God don't even tempt me
[Laughter]
show show buddy buddy boy yeah that's
buddy
[Music]
we're gone oh there is my Tweety bully
what is that
he's such a good boy
okay back to me now yes
back to
yeah I got it I got what you guys were
doing that's really clever
really clever
uh thanks for the super sticker oh my
gosh
um
wow finally subbed after realizing I've
watched every new video viewers for four
months that's nice but I think that's
also like a reflection on my inability
to like uh promote myself
um that's good that's good though
um
um hey can you please shame my brother
Daniel if you're not subscribing so I
can clip it and send it to him he still
won't subscribe Daniel
listen to your brother
And subscribe to woman carrying man man
Karen which is the superior Channel man
caring thing
and um he's just promoting woman caring
man because he realized after 3K
balance the bank account so when he
leaves me for Deborah
um you know he's
but hey Josh you got me reading the
Parker books thank you muchly thanks
Josh that is awesome the Parker books
are fantastic I'm on the final eight so
I'm in the last stretch of Parker books
and I'm going to do a long video about
it um at some point
um
thank you so much everyone for being
here
um yeah this is cool so I do want to get
into like what we're going to talk about
the schedule of things
um so maybe for the next like five
minutes I'm just going to be looking
through chat answering well I'm going to
be doing that the whole time yeah but
then um we're going to be asking you
questions about the channel about things
you guys want to see and uh you know
just building some do you want me to
read a chat so that you can
say or do you want to read the chat well
I think we both need to because there's
470 people here which is kind of crazy
yeah I just spent 200 you spent two
hundred dollars I failed to get you but
I succeeded to make you smile which is
even more fun all right well that's very
sweet I appreciate you guys listen to
more than me
I I spend everything I have to make him
smile and he like he looks at me
I think you have my mom's hairstyle it
did that on purpose
um
why are you so classy now because I have
300 000 subscribers and I'm going to be
trying now you know and like the big
thing was like I don't try anymore but
now I'm going to try you know I'm going
to like host
um twice a day
in terms of day I'm going to be doing a
really long video essays like like
really long video essays and I'm going
to be posting shorts you know so get
ready for that uh subscribers we'll
shoot through the roof and I won't
remember any of you guys because I'll be
on Mr beats Mr beasts yeah soon enough
you won't remember me so
what what
I should do more with 40 I'm like
Superman on sorry guys
um I I feel like I'm doing good thank
you uh Ray me can you please tell my
friend uh to wake up wake up
okay ever still in the picture yeah kind
of I don't know
means he doesn't talk about her but in
sleep he goes Deborah only if I had
another chance
[Music]
I feel like you can go through the
streams and kind of see me
um slowly losing my like um
ability my my composure
um what
oh right there hey thanks for the five
Curtis have you ever watched a Neil
Breen film would love to get a woman
review of one of his masterpieces I
don't know I don't know I mean I haven't
seen them I like seeing people watch
them but I don't have I don't know I
don't know if I didn't really get into
that I you know what I need to do is get
some friends
well you're my best friend but I need to
get some other friends to laugh at
movies with because those are that's
really fun thanks thanks for the the
five Raymond congrats do you think a bad
ending one's a good show in my opinion
it doesn't also origin of the man caring
thing name all right this is important
this is a key to the channel
um well first off Bad Endings no not
necessarily because shows are you can
pretend like it never happened uh yeah
but
um
I I no I think with the movie It's the
group because you need like a conclusive
ending shows
um origin of the man caring thing name
all right straight up it's from
I wrote
yeah no that's from a Wallace Stevens
poem called man carrying thing
um and I thought it was funny which
Wallace Stephen got it from me the
content of the film doesn't bear much
um meaning to the channel itself but um
yeah the name I thought was funny and I
used that randomly as I mean as most
YouTubers will probably tell you you're
just picking any random name that's just
becomes it you know you can't really you
know because you just try things out and
see what works and who knows if
my gaming career picked up that's what
I'd be that's what I'd I'd be doing you
know it's a very safe name because it
became like a mine Minecraft gamer then
he's just going to be like a man curing
thing you know
you know
yeah that's right congrats thanks for
the five some guy you're just some guy
congrats have you ever read Foundation
if you do uh if so do you have an
opinion on the Apple TV adaptation I've
read some of foundation back when I was
so it's been a long time I have been
wanting to read it again
um or you know read the full series
again uh but if uh no I haven't seen the
Apple TV adaptation it just looks boring
like I don't know I'm sorry Apple TV but
I don't know I think it's kind of a bad
series to adapt into a show Apple TV has
some good stuff don't listen to me
um
Nancy why are you so funny I'm not to be
truly honest I think that you know you
see you watch me in 30 second Clips
um I'm anyone will tell you she'll tell
you that I'm very quiet in person and
not very well no he tells me that like
when I say you're not funny he says I'll
be funny when I hand you divorce
divorce what
I'm just insecure I'm sorry I'm talking
so much about our pending divorce we're
not getting divorced guys come on
I
will have that money yeah uh but I'll
stay with him
okay then I'll sign a prenup saying that
he can't have any of my money that I
took from him
this is getting really juicy this is
getting so interesting just kidding tips
um I'm at a lunch break in a Barnes
Noble break room eating a chicken pot
pie hello I think that's the ideal way
to be watching any of my videos you know
just like you're standing up just like
in a you know tight space are you where
Patrick is wolves I'm aware yes I I I've
seen this video absolutely
um
wow you guys are really like here this
is crazy I think um wow
thank you my friend cigar is now awake
good I'm I'm really glad you just all
you had to do was pay me money and I
mean was it worth it I don't know I
would ask him
um
they have Severance watch Severance
Severance is really good oh my gosh I
just hope oh my God it's it's the legend
uh kunkin dassner
um I don't I don't know why I always
think his actual name is kunkin I know
it's not but great great YouTuber and um
but I won't do a backflip I mean maybe
if you paid me money but yeah that's
because I'm I'm such a businessman you
know I'm on Mr Beast level now I have to
like be on the grind set you know so I
can only do those if like a company
wants to pay me to like do a backflip
maybe I'll do that but you know I'm just
I'm just on the I'm on the grind set you
know
um
have you ever watched a Neil green film
did I feel like it
did am I behind what is going on you are
very behind I'm so sorry everyone
because you keep scrolling up and down
and gets lost in the chat it's like so
chaotic to watch I'm like just keep
scrolling stop going up and down
I'm stressing you out a little bit I
think I'm just super organized
yeah this is like a microcosm of our
working days
Kings in general direction
I love this guys Kings in general is
fantastic
um man there's so many it's what's cool
about like um doing more
I mean just getting more subscribers or
whatever and like connecting with other
YouTubers is you know people you enjoy
watching and then talking about YouTube
because um
um you know it's a very like weird kind
of thing to be doing and you kind of
feel isolated a lot of the time and
talking to anyone outside of your
immediate bubble is you know makes you
feel a little more normal yeah I make
him feel abnormal that's what he's
saying is this a sketch about streamers
I'm going to leave that up to your
interpretation I don't I don't like to
tell the audience what to think
but
um yes
MCT important question Barnes Noble or
Half Price Books uh if you have half
price books in your area so
um first off small used bookstores the
best those are my absolute go-to
um then Half Price Books depends uh you
know it depends on what they have I'm
not a huge fan of Half Price Books but
then Barnes Noble is you know yeah all
right it's fine I I like Barnes and
Noble because I can have coffee while I
like read books for free
uh drunk it says fly out to Washington
and we'll do a simultaneous flip and try
to get sponsored by big backflip I hear
they they pay a lot you know so I mean
if we do do that that might be really I
cut it but the thing is I live in
Washington so you know I might be closer
to you than you realize I don't know I
don't mean to to scare anyone
realization that we live in Washington
um we've been about a year when's the
divorce stream
um yeah I don't
we're gonna do a pay-per-view
um maybe kind of talk to HBO see if we
can do like the fourth stream does HBO
do pay-per-viewing I have no idea
a lot of touch
um you know one thing that I'm waiting
for as soon as like I'll set him in
divorce paper he's an amazing writer
so as soon as he gets his first look out
there whoa you're gonna hear some news
about Nadia you know taking his money
and drama and stuff like that but but
the book is just going to be about
um divorce you know how to how to game
the algorithm which is really all I care
about you know now
um
would I fight in the Creator Clash um
the only person I will fight is
um uh Greg gay reg uh Greg
and yeah we made an agreement I will
fight him a couple months ago and I will
fight him you know that's that's just
going to happen I miss short-haired
Drake you know
you know but he's he's on another plane
he's not another reality because it's a
diva Jake just so you guys know yeah
because I'm I'm on I'm at a new phase
you know I'm I'm I'm on the grind set
you know and I don't have time to cut my
hair
so so that's that's really that's really
important last time I cut it and he said
he will never let me touch it again
um you remember when I cut your hair
cute yeah she did cut my hair once and
during colvid and he
he was so not happy with the results
I think I hyped it up apparently too
much of my skills though yeah would you
fight Daniel Green and Creator Clash I
could never do that to him he's too nice
but
um if again if I got money from it
absolutely
you kind of have to see where my brain
is you know
um so for sure
for sure but um I would I would try not
to
um and you know I'm I'm big I think
people don't realize that I'm I'm six or
I'm 220 pounds of muscle
so I I think I I'd be a formidable foe
except for the fact that I'm a pacifist
and a vegan you know so who knows
um
reading a little life because of you oh
God you know don't don't credit me for
that I feel like I try to get people to
not read it
um but uh I mean you might enjoy it but
it is kind of a depressing book
who would Nadia fight in Creator Clash
who do you want to fight I don't know
any YouTubers no
no she would fight me I don't know I
don't
what would you do for a sub I'd give you
a cookie
how about that it's pretty good
um anyways I have some questions all
right well first go through some of
these right
I feel like I went through those yeah I
don't know because you keep throwing up
and down go down no I I was on the very
bottom oh okay
yeah I think I went through those
if you saw him scroll through the chat
you're gonna see a chaoticness
I don't know it's like this
okay oh don't okay well I don't know
about that what would he do for a sub he
would strip
but I don't let him I have to I have to
get the dog okay thank you you're my
hero
um how Okay so random question how do
you get inspiration for your videos
um I literally I'll just sit in the room
for hours
um just grinding my brain down into like
the blunt ends of all the neurons and
I'm just like
suffering and decaffeinated and lacking
sleep and then I just um go on Twitter
and see what's popular and make a skit
about that
or inspiration comes I don't know so the
thing about like
all right here's the thing and I
actually want to ask you guys some
questions for real because I'm curious
and you know I don't I don't stream very
much
what
video
um
made you like a viewer like a regular
viewer of the channel can any do you
guys know can you name the video do you
is there something that like you guys
remember seeing was it like a book video
early on was it one of the skits I'm I'm
genuinely curious hey Nico thanks for
the five you know so for everyone
donating money it's super
generous but I don't want to for real I
know I'm for like for real though you
guys don't have to be be doing that
that's um
um not this is about this is about me
performing parasocial bonds with all of
you you know and um
and I think that's that's like my goal
you know is I want you guys to be
obsessed with me in a way that um
might scare people a Victorian child
um
celebrity interview sketch yeah you know
I used to do more of those because it
was easier during like um covet era
because you could
there were a lot of like Zoom related
interviews you know like there's there's
less of that now people are doing
interviews with celebrities in person
unless just like because you need them
like looking at you so um acting
compilation one yeah yeah
for sure for sure
oh please oh my goodness
oh
my gosh
oh my God okay you now you everyone
subscribed to babu's channel it's called
Uh it's called man carrying dog
I saw you on a debate or game show like
video with dado green and your
personality there piqued my interest I
think I subscribed after I saw skit whoa
that's cool I mean
um yeah absolutely I feel like um
that's I I'm I I I keep I keep
correcting what I'm gonna say like off
the top of my head because I feel like
you know it might be
I don't know it's weird because when
you're when you're doing a live stream
you have to like
thank you personality you know because
my real personality is like I'm on the
grind set I have to like win I have to
be you know I'm I'm much like uh Mr
Beast in the way where like I'm
streaming but I'm also thinking about
the next 10 thumbnails you know I'm also
I'm also editing a video in my head so
I'm kind of like on on that level and
all right we've got some
donations I'm going to get to
um
thanks for the 20. uh it's too late to
say I don't have to I've already done it
I I don't know what that's in reference
to but but thanks
um
hey thanks for the five hi I'm uh you're
the friend uh thanks for waking me up I
showed my lane from your spider verse
video and watch with my cool friend
instead thank you that's really
interesting
um a lot of people really like that
spider verse video I I realized and that
was a really nice thing to see
um
because that was basically our reaction
when we saw it you know I think Nadia
was really excited about the ending and
that was kind of like
outcome of you guys you know good movie
though fantastic movie
I don't know why I said fantastic like
that
um
uh I don't know what what this whole
thing between between everyone is here
right now
um
so I absolutely love the concept of your
channels it's brought me in long-form
content kept me around killing it on
here do much love that's really sweet
and and thank you so much turn into
tables you know that is how you win you
know in in the end it's very
it's it's it's very calculated and you
know I just I've never been to capture
everyone's attention at all times so
short short videos
I love doing the short videos but I the
long videos are I mean we'll see I have
some long stuff in the works I have some
lock stuff of course
um a Stephen King gets his ideas
um that one was that one was really fun
I really like doing that with Daniel he
sent me so many good takes of him with
like powder on his mouth
wow yeah yeah so okay so it seems like a
lot of a lot of uh people saw like
Brandon Sanderson stuff
um
yeah
it's kind of like homelander
how does homelander sound I I don't know
I feel like I've people have told me I
sound like Kendall Roy from session
you're Patrick Bateman for real wow yeah
totally
have I read sexually no
um
I haven't read Scyther but I want to you
know R.I.P Cormac McCarthy
um
you kind of look like a baller chatter
guys
this is what I want to hear this is the
kind of I need to be hearing you
know like we're on the grind set where
we're we're reading non-fiction works
about
the inbros you know
I'm much like Mr Beans yep that's
something you can quote me on for for
all time
um
have I read Infinite Jest actually
yes no I don't know I really haven't
I have not read infinite jazz
favorite Sam Rainey movie oh it's got to
be uh Spider-Man 2. yeah or oh no what
am I thinking no it's Evil Dead the
original one
um
hey Raymond thanks for the five first
video I saw was the thing video essays
doodle smart funny as hell that whole
thank you very much that um yeah that
that is yeah I appreciate that that was
a fun one to make
um hey potato is this the YouTube famous
rain Wilson
retweetermaker yeah that's what I'm
gonna put on like my uh my uh business
cards because I have
you know because I'm on the ground Set
uh yeah that was uh it has been around
for forever I love potato you're the
best
um the book videos I tricked through
this gets incredible
the five and for being honest yeah but
but you're still watching them you know
that's that's that's what matters you
know
um the book videos you got to be
grudgingly get through you know some
people are the other way around you know
um do I wear wigs yeah this is a wig
it's a it's a very very elaborate wig
um
what a nerd I know I know guys I'm Legit
a nerd you know if you met me in real
life you'd be like wow
um
you know that's that's like a boring
person
um is that Tom Cruise yeah
that's right I am Tom Cruise Phantom
Tollbooth review when pleasing I love
the fanduels I love that so much that's
my childhood
um and thanks for the two
um four eyes we're pulling out some like
old school
um insults like like like I haven't
heard that since like the second grade
maybe
um CT won that's that when to goon
um Cormac McCarthy video that was that
was quite impressive
um my chat about it being too late was a
reference he's saying we didn't donate I
felt the need to claim because
thanks for the tab I mean I like that
you clarified because it did seem like
too late
talk to myself about being in your state
you know
um
someone's at Orlando
yeah
of course
well have you read Tad Williams you're
my favorite Sigma male yeah that's
that's me I mean I'm I'm Sigma available
and no I have not read Ted Williams I
have a couple of people
I need to read that but thanks
I appreciate that okay will you wear wig
what's wigs I don't know what's going on
my hair not good enough for you guys
I'll cut my hair and put it in as glue
it in his head back home
that was a really old yeah that was a
that was one of the early old ones I did
um
any updates on Joshua as far as the
bottom of the Grand Canyon
um
I instantly became subscriber when man
showed up at my door and handed me a
business card
um yeah you know that's what I do that's
like the old school kind of like old old
politics and stuff you gotta do to keep
people engaged to show up at their door
give them a business card you know you
know what you know what it's like he's a
politician I'm the first lady
I feel like I'm the first lady though in
this situation you're you're kind of in
charge here hey are you saying first
ladies can't be in charge no no I mean
he's thinking about Deborah right now
thank you see his face that's how he
looks like when he's like Deborah
um
gotta go again I'm so glad I'm like two
minutes late every to every concept here
but
if you read any short stories from Marie
Bradbury yeah actually on that shelf
right here I have a signed copy of Ray
Bradbury short Story collection which is
one of my proudest
proudest
possessions
yeah
um
Quentin Tarantino or Monster says he
writes video yeah yeah so on the second
Channel I do the ranking videos
occasionally uh Tarantino I could
definitely do Scorsese or some sort of
crazy ones that I'm missing I need to
watch like bringing out the dead and
stuff but um I the ranking ones I try to
do of directors who I've seen like most
of their movies
um
do you like to try I haven't uh seen the
trial because I have never been able to
see like a good print of it
um
uh I haven't read the towels yeah
are you excited for Barbie and if so
will you watch it before okay listen up
everyone
this is important
because I know a lot of you are going to
be uh trying to do the Barbie
Oppenheimer uh double double feature you
know coming up and um
there are some debates about the order
in which it should be viewed so first
you watch Oppenheimer all right catch a
matinee
get thoroughly impressed by Nolan's
Brilliance and and and see the Despair
and then
go out
have a few drinks
half a meal and watch Barbie with all
your friends there you go
that's how you do it
that's not how I'm gonna do it though
because I'm not gonna see two movies
that's too much
I don't see why you don't watch both oh
come on you know people are going to do
that you know people are gonna do that
blue jay
I know you
I Read To Kill a Mockingbird yeah
opinion on the new Indiana Jones movie
so guys here's what you do
I'm plugging this really hard because I
care a lot about the second Channel
so
um go subscribe to woman pairing and
just put out a review on the Indiana
Jones movie the new one and uh we
basically argued for like 18 minutes
which is every second of our life we
have a very healthy relationship
I'm in it just for the money
well good that's I mean that's good
so the profile pick for woman caring man
the man is carrying the woman so
grammatically if we think about it is it
woman carrying a man or is it is
a woman caring man
is it a man carrying a child
or grand caring child
um
will you read neon ghosts fun fact I
have read it already
um because I beta read it for with uh
you know early on been in the stage I
haven't read the newest version of me uh
but I have received it and I will read
it but it's a it's a very fun book and
um you guys should definitely support
Daniel
um I enjoyed it quite a bit
um
did you miss someone on top the blue one
or no
you like British actors what kind of
question is that
what kind of question is
no screw them
actors you know why why
and talk like things
blindfold bridge is that your British
accent is it a British accent are you
saying I'm bad
I want to have a cup of tea to talk to
you
oh good
that's me
um can you read one piece uh no because
I'm reading Dragon Ball right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah whoever sent it to him
thank you so much that's actually my
childhood like I was I'm obsessed with
dragon balls all over my childhood and
now
because you know we're now at the time
level what kind of question would you
believe in Bigfoot Bigfoot's not
something you believe in Bigfoot is
something that you either know or you
don't know and I know that Bigfoot is
real
yes
kind of a bit fun
favorite genre changes with time depends
on the year or whatever but right now
it's crime I like pulpy hard-boiled
crime
um which is funny because you guys
cannot be into that when it met you but
now I'm brainwashed you
a favorite Forum film this is so hard I
mean there's just there's too many too
many
um I love Fellini I love Knights of
kiberia I love stalker that's not funny
but
um yeah I don't know there's so many I'm
I'm kind of I'm kind of a film fan you
know so I've seen a lot of movies
not not to brag
um he talks about a lot of his films in
the second Channel too though by the way
man what is the meaning of Plankton
farts and dies
um if you have to ask then you've you've
missed it already you've missed it
already almost be some really good fart
that's the part that we all dream
it's a good way to deal
it's like dying your you know intimate
with someone it's like ah
it's good
it's a good way to go I dream to die
with a great fart
anyways um I feel I know you feel sorry
for him favorite movie of 22 or 23 so
far uh so favorite movie of this year so
what's your favorite movie
yeah that we saw this year
new one for real
for real for real
mine is
Beau was afraid
you love anxiety films yeah
Indiana Jones
and I'm going to say it because of that
reaction
I don't understand what's not to love
about indie
and some action you know
um okay so what
you're gonna really like is
um what's that movie
um oh God who's that film that we
watched we watched it earlier this year
or last year it was the Hollywood with
this big thing that I really did and as
I thought about it I really loved it
Babylon oh yeah that was the end of the
last year was it really yeah I'm getting
my timelines mixed but I really like the
film Babylon I hated it when we watched
it you walked out of the movie several
times I it's just so gross and then it
was really
and you know I'm a baby but as I thought
about it more in the week I was like
really that was really good why didn't I
appreciate it it's one of those films
and you know it's it's kind of like
kind of like when you are mentally abuse
me
and say that you're too good enough for
me now that you have 300K I'd say
something I'm so sorry I feel so bad why
would you say this but then as I think
about it more I'm like actually that's
great because I'm married to him
I associate
and at the top of the list
um you know it's kind of a big deal yeah
I get to I get to keep the money yeah so
um so yeah I'm like that's actually what
really good at mental abuse okay yeah
okay well good I'm glad you know that's
I'm glad that things worked out there
but hey Sam thanks for the five Andrew
Clavin is one of the best hard-boiled
crime mystery thriller UPS I've read and
Stephen Curry oh send you his books will
you read them I'll I mean I mean I no
promises but I yeah I'm definitely going
to look him up you don't have to send me
anything
um not telling you to send me anything
but you know if you do I'll definitely
check them out
[Laughter]
he's like look at the book look he's
like you know
I love books
it's great for me because I can be like
very bad person and mentally abuse him
and then I'll just tell him honey why
don't you go to the PO box and he's
happy again he forgets all this trauma
that I put him through and it's great
it's able to be more shitty but at least
I'm self-aware that's good I I've I'm
currently well one of the books I've
been reading is no longer human I've
found it a total slog really hard to get
through and I get that sort of the point
you know but it's just it's really
really hard to read Because The
Narrative is
yeah so I mean that'll be like a video
I'm sure at some point hey thanks for
the five Alec what even is the thing
you're carrying man
um that's such a good question and one
that could be answered in a few words or
in several minutes but I I don't think
I'll get into that because
it's more of a philosophical question
you know
what what does anyone carry
made me cry
um are you announcing the gaming channel
this stream or is that being
stream
um the face reveal stream happened a
while ago uh thanks for the five gaming
channel Yeah so basically I'm turning
this entire Channel now that we're at
300K I can actually pursue what I'm what
I really want and what's going to earn
me the most money so the Upstream every
day
just only up and uh until I
and then that's that'll just be the
streams and then I'll do like the
channel so hope you guys because I just
realized doing this it's too much it's
too much work you know I have to like
think about stuff you know you know like
my brain is tired you know for me what
the heck
yeah
do I have the letterbox yep I have a
letterbox you guys can follow me on
litter box I I watch movies I am a
cinephile what is the letterbox is it a
box that's letter
uh start with his books True Crime and
don't say a word no okay I will thank
you Sam
um I will check out uh those books I'm
trying to get into James Elroy right now
um
we have sold me books
kind of like we can make a bed for just
the books
I have not read are you there God it's
me Kevin Spacey
I'm not
um
maybe I'll check it out
I prefer my crime stories Connie's tied
up yeah for sure
race can still stream when uh yeah I'm
gonna do like a dream kind of thing and
just put the math back on
um forever
um
I always wondered could you do like 10
new books of your video or at least
first half 23 since it's July
um I I like to just kind of uh uh group
in books read lately and then at the end
of the year I'll do like my favorite
five books or whatever
um but you know it depends some months I
read like 10 books on my read you know
um uh I'm a little erratic that way
um
literature not not a ton I mean it's
it's a shameful it's not something I've
read too much of I I do love like
everyone does uh Gabriel Marquez
um
so yeah I mean there's there's more I
definitely want to explore there
I like how Nadia made this joke about
letterbox and they just have their
smiling to herself that's what it's like
living with her that's what I'll she'll
just like say a joke and then I just
look at her and then she just laughs
I find myself
um
so with books it really depends some
books are sure like no longer human is
really short talking I can read it uh
like I could read it fast but it's like
it's just it's hard for me to get
motivated to read it
um
I don't know
um and then some long books I can like
speak right through
um so
favorite quotes I can't I'm not I can do
like Javier call it
call it but that's not even an
impression that's like half an
impression
um you're cute
I have to know what I'm calling it for
you're cute just call it
come back on chatting with us anytime
absolutely
yes oh gotcha thanks David yeah yeah
um
Mr equal film I assume you're talking
about Star Wars the best one is
obviously episode three hello
um
let's see let's see
are you real that's actually a um
a terrible question
I don't know I clicked I'm just clicking
on random questions
um
let's see let's see
uh let's see how long did it take you to
finish the leaves it took me would you
play the Duma
um maybe I would play the mod I don't
know I just don't love Hazard leaves
like it took me a while to get through
uh just because it was like I really had
to force myself to read um the like main
part of it is really interesting I like
the house stuff that so much of that
book is what people don't usually talk
about it's all this meta
meta stuff with uh Johnny true and all
that I just think it's very tedious
um
top five cereal thanks for the two top
five cereal
um Reese's Puffs
don't get mad Reese's Puffs is number
one
and I'd say Cinnamon Toast Crunch
on ethereal lately do you like any of
those they're fine they're fine but
Reese's Puffs is right up top and then I
don't know and then I don't really care
that much about cereal he likes anything
Reese's I've been in the toast a lot
lately you know just like buttered toast
with with some jelly or some peanut
butter you know what else you're into
lately tortilla with mayonnaise
and you make like a roll of it
yeah
um hey thanks for the five what would
you do if Anton sugar appeared to you
with a coin like a serious
how how can you say this is a serious
hypothetical what would I do if a
fictional character walked up to me I'd
be like hey nice costume dude
I don't know
I don't know that's such a good movie I
love new country you haven't seen that
right No Country for Old Men I don't
think you've seen that
I've been here since 303k Legend yeah
uh are you and Rayne Wilson friends now
we are he just doesn't realize it yet
um
uh-huh
if you could talk to your younger self
with your younger self would you talk to
and what would you say this is actually
kind of a deep question and I'm going to
respond to it with the kind of lack of
seriousness that it deserves
um because I have a bunch of issues but
I will say
that I would talk through myself as like
a
in high school and say
just
start posting videos because you are
super good at it and you're going to be
the next Mr Beast
I would say I'm glad that he was so
broken when I met him because I was able
to just really you know make sure that
he gets with me because if he was at the
level that he's now you know he would be
like
b b word please
is this the uh Jules polarski the author
of a book that I am soon to read uh you
say Reese's the same way I do
yes I I don't know does everyone say
recently braces
races races
favorite time travel movie
ah Back to the Future I mean I don't
know
you look like a guy who likes toast I
don't know what that means
real job stream when
um yeah I mean my real job will be
um fortnite soon
um
thank you I've appreciate that
you like Oh Brother Where Art Thou yeah
that's another one I want to do like
Coen Brothers uh ranking most likely but
there's a few more I have to see I
haven't seen the man who wasn't there I
haven't seen
oh I haven't seen Martin Fink I want to
watch that one and I recently saw
Millers Crossing for the first time
really good I have a hot take question
oh please okay
do you ever want to remember what it was
like in the womb
no
you don't ever think about that I'm I'm
I'm black curiosity in many many areas
yeah try to do mindfulness meditation
and always think about that no and I try
to like picture it and then I don't know
if it's my real memory or if it's like
something that afford
whenever I try to meditate I just start
playing Subway Surfer and then I just
that that makes me happier instead so I
don't meditate yeah whenever I think
about me and my mom's own about me like
literally
um I shouldn't say that okay
um I do full-time YouTube now yes I'm
very fortunate to be doing YouTube
full-time but it's also we have
dual incomes you know and it has a an
actual job so we're we're doing I have a
job that where I I dominate man carrying
and steal the money
is a red flag I think that's what she's
going for right you spell my name wrong
not to you
everyone else
wait yeah this is Nadia gives the same
energy that your kids have I Inspire him
oh yeah yeah in the morning you know
when he says Deborah I say what
and then he's so afraid shaking up
I want to put you in a skip but she
never wants to be in one
I am not paid enough
I'd have to really and I don't want you
to unionize you know
I know what I deserve and it's not what
you're off
you're off more
yeah that's so true
um hey ask him can you give me your soul
instead as a payment but he says no it's
some devil stuff and you know I don't
understand him for real though the game
that I play the most probably is temples
like I don't know it is like a calming
thing you paid you played um Mario with
me
um I'm really not much of a game of a
gamer but I do like Tetris because it's
I can listen to a podcast and play it or
something whatever
please be honest kid yeah you should be
in a skit like when you are
oh my God that's a great idea I can be
in a skit and then we'll make a divorce
I can say that as like this is my
channel and then I can have half of your
subscribers and then I can like dominate
the world because I'll like I'll like
make the half of the subscribers that
are unfortunate enough to get on my side
I'll make them pay every single day
taxes
you know I I have I think I'm on to
something please don't encourage that
this is
this is not a path we want to go down
you the way you carry the thing is
unbelievable I must say thank you and
thanks
very nice congratulations on taking over
from Jason Siegel and David Foster
Wallace sequel this Anthology Doctor Who
style format is going to be lit thank
you thank you for the five and uh Jason
Siegel is uh is great I know what movie
you're talking about he played David
Foster Wallace and I my hair is in that
vein at the moment
confirmed
she's the real streamer I think you
should start like streaming I
would be canceled in two seconds because
all I would think about was
taste in the afterlife Army Hammer
we need a divorce joke counter
divorce Joe counter
yeah they love you I mean they're I mean
she's really the star this whole this
whole lot he's scared of me
actually this is like the best time
everyone's watching
hey thanks for the five how do you feel
about the idea that Tick Tock users
would make the judge if a Blood Meridian
movie was made I think that'd be awesome
you know I think that um
I think it'd be so funny
so wrong and it just
I don't know I feel like there's already
we've reached a level where the sigma
edits are become so ironic like it's the
parody of a parody of a parody I'm sure
jreck would like explain better
like
like where does the joke begin or and
uh fever band of all time
oh that's my stomach growling
[Laughter]
here
I'm fine guys
or am I
play Red Dead Redemption 2. I used to
play Red Dead uh yeah way back when oh
my God buddy when is song of Suzanne
review right now
seeing that coming
all right I still have that much more to
go but
um
oh question for Nadia what is your
favorite skit from men caring thing yeah
tell me
ew oh let's see she doesn't watch my
videos
I mean him the right
which was that a lot of them
well sometimes no I like the one that
you made about music
that was our first day
I like everything you're like
you thought I was just so frustrated
with me no yeah that's one of my
favorite skills I think because that is
from like one of our earliest dates when
I was like what kind of music do you
like and she's like everything and I was
annoyed because I'm like that's a
question to figure out your personality
yeah
being like like what everything looks
like and then you're like judging me I
was like
pretentious
what's your opinion on doing this 300K
celebration it's very awesome I feel
very grateful to everyone here real for
real
sincere
I read one piece if this starts a trend
of people pestering me at that one piece
we watched an episode of One Piece do
you remember we watched the first
episode
yeah yeah
is Nadia Patrick Baker American Psycho
so the way that I prepared in the
morning is by putting some lotion on my
face I hear that it really soft yeah
then I prepared my body by putting
clothes off and then I feed it from
protein because I hear that it builds
muscles and it also means great for when
you want to kill someone randomly at
night
um
oh is are you done two different but for
now do you guys have a business card
because that would really really piss me
off if it's better than mine what did I
do before YouTube I did I did all sorts
of crap and I sucked at it you scared me
what do you mean Halloween oh yeah no I
mean when we were living in LA and I I
did all like different odd jobs like and
I was bad I mean that Universal Studios
every season before Four Seasons Michael
Myers a lot I was the Ghostbusters maze
actually the most celebrities I've ever
seen or been around us too bad because
one time Ariana
cultures maze
for real and I was I just got off a
shift where I was doing like I was like
Bill Murray character
and what nothing go ahead you're making
fun of me
um name dropping Ariana Grande you know
we're best but it was so funny because
she she just came in backstage because
celebrities they like don't want to be
in the crowds whatever and I was just
the first one standing there and she had
all this energy because she just came
through the Maze and I'm just like tired
of it's like 1am you know and I'm
just drinking water chickens and
backstage looks at me points at me and
says Ghostbusters
and I was just like
you know you don't have time to react
and I just like kind of stared at her
and then she just like quickly just like
walked away with her like uh her group
and her bodyguard and was just like
I feel bad I I didn't get any kind of
content when she was expecting backstage
at that event I'm sure that you remember
that and it's guarded by that energy
that you gave her thanks Blue Jay I
appreciate it thanks for coming in
hmm
theme
uh yeah
that is on that is Nadia real I don't
know I don't know he tells me all the
time and he says are you real because
I'm so insane and he just you know he
knew what he was getting into I do not I
do not own a copy of that but
um
hey thanks hopefully average man one of
my favorite uh booktube channels go
check him out
was uh Nadia into the movies before
being with you yeah
I've never seen movies before okay this
is
once you get her started she can't stop
um
I just wanted to ask if you Brett could
read The Basketball Diaries um yeah I'll
check it out I'll try to to uh remember
that or look out for that for sure
um
let's see
that's not imperative and that's I don't
think that's a question that's I mean
it's a lot but I mean that's I don't
need to get into that
um I hear that if you don't like pee
every hour you're doing something wrong
um a goblin is loose Indie and in the
chat right now so Daniel has asked uh
where were you conceived I asked him
that all the time that's like literally
what I ask him all the time you know why
because he's so perfect I want to make
sure I understand I try to ask my
mother-in-law that she thinks it's
inappropriate and he said that you know
the psychopath I don't understand
because it's a normal question
but yeah where are you confused I I
think that that your response was
appropriate to that question yeah
father-in-law if you're in the chat
hunger with his mom but you know perfect
being so it'd be good for me to know for
myself and I don't think it's an
appropriate question at all to ask for
In-laws I think it bonds you and I don't
know why they don't understand that of
course yeah maybe if I'm getting too
deep into my personal life but it really
makes me emotional that no one gives me
that answer like it kind of has a
barrier between us now of course yeah of
course so Ben has asked what's your
thoughts on geopolitical situation
between north and south of England and I
say it's complicated
you know and I like to not you know have
opinions on things that are
controversial
um your your cousin
um Dominic is in the South that England
I think I like the Beatles favorite band
is
Electric Light Orchestra you know which
is they're just
um
if I read of course of course I was a
child once I was once once innocent and
happy
oh what's happening
thanks well you know the crushing
despair of just life is you know with me
not with you you make me happy but you
know why do I make you happy or do I
make a question your decisions in life
especially right now
oh I'm glad that you thought about that
I didn't think
I did not think
um
have you met my dad no I don't I don't
think so
more book video please absolutely
absolutely more big I've been reading a
lot like for real for real for real um I
just haven't done a book because I don't
know why
um
did he carry a thing already
um no I mean I guess not
um
when will be I've when I don't know I'd
be fighting other live streamers um I
don't do that I believe in peace
um mbti type so
I am an infp
yes right
which what a drag what am I what a drag
you are an i-n-e-j
then what does it say what's the first
thing it says it says they are like the
best no it says the rarest no it says
it's hard to be at the at the top and no
one knows them
never let him live that down she loves
to say that yeah because he's the one
who made me do the test and all night
hey thanks thanks for the five the real
men with the things we carry along the
way it's very deep very profound
very profound it makes you think
about everything
um favorite song by ELO ah I it's so
hard I mean they're all
so good I'll tell you my favorite ELO
album is a new new world record
that is just beginning to end perfect
every every uh every song is the hit uh
how old are you I turned 26.
believe it or not this August 22nd
um yeah August 22nd so my birthday
everyone since I'm older
I don't know good for me
um
have you ever died can you die look at
this look at the stream I am Eternal
come on I am Eternal I will never die
ever
um someone's asking about Deborah and I
think we should
teach the history of it
scroll down because I I need to talk
about this part okay where where down
when am I gonna have a case right with
Daniel soon I mean we just need to to
plan on on you know
on the money
wait who's Deborah trap thank you
Admiral can you please
emotional I
think Deborah
he's my twin your twin
that he married before me he chose her
before me she went with Joshua
for kiss kids Michael I'm sorry I it was
going to be a straight that Mom slash
Aunt to you but you know
let's do Mexico because he wouldn't
leave her alone and then I think he
would desperately need for love that
okay fine you'll do you look like her
that's enough
um but last night
he mentioned her name again
so now I'm here waiting for our 300 Subs
to turn into a million Subs so that I
can finally divorce him take the money
Revenge
but then because I love him so much I'll
remarry him but then sign a prenup that
says you can't take any money that I
took from you
but I can take more money when you make
more
and then I'll divorce him a second time
and keep repeating that pattern so that
my bank account builds up and then his
goes down he finally has no reason to
stay with me
so today is a celebration for him but
it's really sad for me because he keeps
calling me a groupie now and
it's hard
did I answer that question do you have
anything to add no that's good
um is Get Shorty representative of other
Elmore Leonard books I'd say it's maybe
two representative I I think that my
issue with Elmore I love Elmore Leonard
but a lot of his books uh start to blend
together and he wrote a lot but you know
you can't remember I'm gonna look at
Stephen King and you start to repeat
things characters over time
hey thanks for the five name three
countries that start with the letter j
no Jake
that's that's one Jake well thanks for
the five
um
how did you turn into into one being uh
it's just something you're born with you
know you either have it or you don't
hence back to that question how were you
conceived do you believe in life after
death damn that's really it's really
profound question
um I will leave it up to the um
scientists I hope you believe in life
after death
you know die first
I want you to move on just understand I
wouldn't
and I'll form to you on your date as a
ghost and I'll never leave you alone and
I will kill her
through just trauma of just haunting her
so I will say
I hope there's life after death because
my TBR pile will never get finished if
um that's true that's true
yes my parents just ran out of names so
did something happen with our connection
um why does it say that yeah we're
having connection problems oh
well that's lovely
um all right so how long does it take to
go from idea to script to video editing
um it depends you know I I keep like a
list of like a document where all of my
ideas that are good
um so I'll just think about them it's
not it's an idea is just like a couple
of words or just make a subject I don't
know how to like run an interest yet
some are just like fully informed so
sometimes it's like 20 minutes sometimes
it's like oh I have an idea I write it
down and I film it uh and edit it you
know sometimes the process is super
short sometimes it takes me you know six
hours so it depends
um very consistent
thanks for the 20. yeah dark Nathan ooh
ooh it reminds me of Nathan for you
oh yeah yeah I love anything for you me
too
I have read Jurassic Park and I
absolutely love Jurassic Park I've read
it in middle school I think
um but yeah fantastic
are you is the connection okay do you
guys I I know we have a we had a little
connection looks like it is right
it's not me then it's okay
yeah I need to do
it
yes I think we do
I think we do
well it's my stomach I think you're
hungry I think we're both hungry
um this has been I keep like thinking
that you guys think I'm farting so I
have to say that it's my stomach yeah
um you know I feel like I might want to
do more streams uh I don't know I think
it's kind of fun but I think I might do
it on Twitch because I kind of like the
idea of people being separate yes but um
I'll I'll keep you guys updated on that
and
so before we sign off
what
I am 6'4 I'm super tall
pretty short right six four
so many muscles
[Laughter]
so many muscles so many muscles uh all
right so before we go
I do want to say thank you very much
sincerely to everyone who has been
watching our stupid videos it is not
stupid
and we're all honored to be with you
can you please be the next dictator of
Our Lives
um but let's join a cult
man carrying cult so before we do that
though we're working on some merch that
we want to do like a March drop because
that's what you're supposed to do when
you're a good YouTuber and um I just
want to say you know this whole thing
like stumbled and stumbled into this
situation and it's been really a thrill
but very fun and I'm just super grateful
you know to everyone who's subscribed
everyone who supports the channel in any
way this was
a dream I never thought was even
realizable so
I'm just incredibly incredibly grateful
so
thank you everyone
thanks for being nice thank you forcing
me to make videos early on when I was
being lame and thought I couldn't you're
welcome
foreign
I'm blessing you yes so um thanks
everyone for being here thank you for
the 300K and we've got some fun stuff
coming up stuff planned you know that's
been in the works for a while so yeah
stay there and
stay carrying things take care
she is the best she is the actual best
being too sentimental for me I know this
is horrible
this isn't what the grind set is about
I'm a damaged person and I can't have so
much sentimental stuff I need toxicity
in my life sorry all right guys uh
all right thanks everyone bye bye have a
lovely day and we will see you all very
soon go subscribe to woman caring man
all right all right bye
all right